Если вы в комнате самый умный то скорее
всего вы не там находитесь получили
предзаказ от одной нас компании сразу на
миллиард тенге Я короче изначально был
как этот Агент как сутенёр он говорит Не
фигня не полетит Всё Стоп А хотя вот
чуть-чуть и надо было дожать 90% того
что сейчас есть сделали вдвоём видите
идею даже Акимат может
[музыка]
давать Приветствую вас друзья на нашем
очередном МБО подкасте а сегодня у нас
очень интересная тема рекомендую
досмотреть это видео до конца потому что
мы будем сегодня говорить о таком
феномене как стартап И это не только об
IT предпринимательстве это также будет о
вообще всех видах стартапа потому что
стартап как сам феномен он присутствует
в любом бизнесе даже если вы завтра
будете открывать кафешку или начинать
любой бизнес это особенно будет полезно
для фрилансеров для топ-менеджеров для
госслужащих и так далее Кто хочет начать
свой бизнес Вы обязательно пройдёте
через стадию стартапа
а Просто многие люди в обществе сложился
стереотип что стартап - это всегда про
it компанию на самом деле все стадии
которые любой бизнес проходит на стадии
а переживает Как it компании так и любые
другие компании и ошибки типичные Вот
дорога к успеху у всех уникальная но
ошибки типичные и мы постараемся сегодня
об этом поговорить поэтому обязательно
досмотрите это видео до конца я уверен
будет много пользы для вас И даже если
вы не сами открываете бизнес то ваши
родственники Друзья вы можете
посоветовать либо репостнуть обязательно
ставьте лайки Подписывайтесь Итак мы
начинаем сегодня очередной г подкаст и
хочу напомнить наш формат мы не собираем
узких специалистов и экспертов это такой
определённый тип посиделок только
бизнесменов на кухне где мы обсуждаем
вообще тренды развитие В каком
направлении двигаемся но в отличие от
кухонных посиделок наше отличие только в
том что мы говорим по какой-то теме и по
делу итак по традиции представляем слева
направо Мар поехали да Очень приятно
здесь находиться Меня мадр зовут Я SEO и
сооснователь компании ушат мы строим для
казахстанцев альтернативу между Яндексом
и общественным транспортом то есть люди
могут утром каждый день по подпис ездит
на работу а у нас сейчас больше 10.000
жителей уже используют вот также
дополнительно дополнительно мы
предоставляем поездки с вокзалов
аэропортов вот этим делом занимаемся у а
это сразу короткий вопрос это а софт это
какое-то приложение или это прямо вы
транспорт организуете да мы а то есть у
нас есть софт и мы сразу организовываем
агрегирующие
Всем привет Меня зовут Артур здесь может
быть большое представление долгое но так
как у нас сегодня тематика стап it и так
далее Я наверное скажу что я кофаундер
такой вещи как как это конструктор
сайтов но чтобы что-то оставить нашему
главному фаундер я мату оставлю поэтому
ещё скажу что я там се вот А подробнее
по продукте уже расскажет это матин ор
это человек который отвечает за
маркетинг занимаюсь такими вещами как
невон в основном и я там главный
коннектор вые об этом не знаете но вы
пользователям стали тоже благодаря мне
благодаря каким-то моим связям и
нетворкингу классно меня значит затащили
да на самом деле в этой компании вот у
нас следующий будет представляться Мада
язы пользователь А сегодня у ва
скоко получается член команды который
вот изначально от идеи и пошла в сторону
реализации путём добавления туда и
программистов и ребят которые занимаются
продуктом и инвесторов и вы одиннадцатый
человек в компании Вы прямо так а сейчас
сколько пользователей сейчас у нас
порядка 32.000
72% по Казахстану и всё остальное мир 6%
с Америки классно сразу переходи к
представлению Спасибо большое за
представление Меня зовут мадат Каримов Я
один из основателей платформы qt это
стартап который позволяет в течение
очень-очень быстрого времени создать
персональный сайт и начать
монетизировать свой контент как цифровой
так и физический мы умеем очень-очень
отлично за несколько минут создавать
абсолютно персональные страницы которые
включают в себя очень много функций
включая хранение данных персонализацию
глубокую аналитику и монетизацию с
момента эквайринга всё в одном всё за
минуты очень радует что в последнее
время в сообщества Где я нахожусь как
минимум один пользователь а даже из пяти
двух-трёх человек является пользователем
нашей платформы и вот сейчас нас в целых
трое я сейчас добавлю маленькую ремарок
А кто на меня подписан в Инстаграме Вы
можете посмотреть там ссылка qt нажмите
и увидите там сразу выходит мой сайт и
вы там сразу же можете оплатить купить
любые мои продукты посмотреть не надо
мне для этого держать отдельный сайт вот
вкратце это особенно хорошо для
криэйтора для тех кто создаёт контент не
надо создавать отдельную вам страничку
сайт просто сделали ссылочку и всё на
стороне qt дальше Угу Всем привет Меня
зовут дожан Жусупов я сооснователь и
руководитель проекта церебро церебро -
это искуственный интеллект занимаемся
диагностикой
инсульта с 2018 года то есть
разрабатываем искуственный интеллект
Сидя в Алмате и с начиная с этого года
начали выходить за границу вот вышли в
Узбекистан сейчас в Саудовской Аравии
работаем и в Соединённые Штаты основной
фокус США Классно а в Соединённых Штатах
Как нам как бы нам повезло нас принял
стэнфорд на акселерацию и как бы это
большой такой как бы адвантаж то что
стэнфорд нас по сути заводит США А
классно классно ещё раз напомню тему
нашего сегодняшнего выпуска - это
стартапы в бизнесе это не только в it
бизнес ещё раз подчеркну понятно что
сегодня хоть ребята больше относятся к
it сфере но так как
традиционно этот термин пришёл из it
сектора но в целом мы будем говорить о
вообще о таком важном первом этапе
любого бизнеса как стартап Давайте
вкратце вначале пробежимся
Кто как стартовал и как по вашему мнению
вообще проходит проходят этапы Как
привлечь первых инвесторов откуда брать
идею в какую нишу идти вы даже смотрите
даже если человек занимается it бизнесом
он ВС равно выбирает нишу бизнес это не
ниша внутри it it бизнес - это просто
способ ведения бизнеса модель
монетизации но это не ниша они точно
также сталкиваются с такими же
проблемами Как и вы у вас просто
проблема Где открыть кафе магазин
ресторан или вообще что открыть отель
заправку также и у них такая же проблема
существует поэтому Давайте поделимся
первое в любом стартапе до того как
стартовать нужно понять первая ниша или
твои ключевые клиенты на которых ты
целишься
и второе какие у них главные боли вот
как вы нашли нишу И как вы нашли боли
своих клиентов на которые потом вы
сориентировать начнём Шан с тебя Ну мы
получается занимались разработкой
софта и нам поступил заказ на разработку
системы автоматизированных медицинских
осмотров Аде откуда поступил со стороны
акимата города Алматы им пришли россияне
им предложили продукт и очень дорого
предложили систему и
как бы управление цифровизации нас
вызвало предложили допустим нам
разработать Ну в смысле Просто как
гипотезу А можно смотрите Дава давайте я
буду извиняюсь буду перебивать потому
что вы айтишники очень часто
разговариваете на птичьем языке
непонятном для людей Для этого вы знаете
есть специально даже отдельная
специальность называется бизнес-аналитик
это тот человек который с простого
бизнесмен ского языка переводит на
этичный
язык Вот люди когда слышат что нам
поступи предложения они с неба во сне
поступило или видение пришло и так далее
Давайте говорить конкретно то есть
позвонил мой старый одноклассник Хайрат
Угу а он работает в акимате и говорит
вот душан Чем занимаешься И ты говоришь
вот бухаю ничего не делаю в депрессии он
говорит Слушай Жан есть возможность
делать Вот вот Давайте вот так чтобы
людям было понятно И это чтоб была как
история хорошо Ну примерно было так что
мы сделали разный софт под заказ
и как бы я в середину как бы своей
истории Вставляю потому что я хочу
рассказать Как ребра появилась и
получается был один зам Акима
который получается тоже можно сказать
там с моего региона с полада и он точно
знал что мы как бы качественная компания
мы умеем там разрабатывать мы работаем
там с иностранными компаниями и нам
просто озвучили типа условно сделайте
такой-то проект в два раза дешевле чем
могут жить допустим россияне типа
сможете сделать Да сможете сделать но
при этом никаких контрактов никаких
гарантий ничего нет это просто вот голые
как бы голая гипотеза Угу А мы начали
делать с ребятами подожди Ну вы поняли
что у вас один заказчик государства Да
мы поняли да что сам по себе проект
заинтересовал потому что это система
автоматизированных медицинских осмотров
и на неё рынок есть в Казахстане Потому
что есть закон прямо под это То есть
получается вот этот звонок был для тебя
больше как идеей да идеи в этом
направлении двигаться как бы имеется как
я в медицину Да вообще попал потом мы
начали делать Вот эту разработку сделали
разработку пошли обратно в Акимат они
соответственно не купили Ну то есть там
тендер шр Да и мы мы не стали нигде
участвовать просто вот не купили мы
пошли с этой разработкой по национальным
компаниям и получили предзаказ от одной
на компаний на сразу на миллиард тенге
Ох нифига се да то есть Рынок есть это
законом заревая процедура по которой
каждый водитель автопарка допустим
каждый сотрудник опасного производства
должен каждый день проходить медосмотр А
вот смотри не поступи этот звонок эта
идея пришла бы тебе Нет не пришла ребята
вот
смотрите для того как стартовать
некоторые делают что бегают по рынку В
поисках возможностей А да возможности -
Это хорошо и это вообще традиционное
понимание что если хочешь делать бизнес
то надо сначала найти возможности так
вот не всегда надо даже искать очень
часто возможности сами падают вот многим
людям тако такие звонки я уверен были от
своих знакомых и так далее и вы это не
рассматривали так вот
А вообще держите в голове две вещи
возможности приходит через два источника
первый источник - это люди это люди
которые звонят говорят предлагают что-то
все возможности в этом мире и ресурсы
для реализации этих возможностей обычно
приходят через людей я просто знаю Из
своего опыта очень часто Я инвестировал
в те проекты Где Круто зарабатывал и я
бы не знал если бы мне не предложили бы
второе возможности приходят через
события
а а события Что такое события события -
это
изменения в обществе в экономике в
государстве и так далее когда происходят
какие-то события то обязательно кому-то
становится плохо кому-то от этого
события становится хорошо сразу начните
думать о том как облегчить боль тех кому
Плохо что вы можете сделать для того
чтобы облегчить боль этих кому стало
плохо поэтому а но здесь нужно понимать
что события приходят к вам через новости
поэтому когда смотрите новости вообще
приучите себя научите себя смотреть на
новости как на источник возможностей а
не то что вот знаете Очень часто люди
смотрят чисто чтобы быть информированным
что там произошла авария что кому-то
что-то постановление какое-то вынесли
ещё что-то кого-то посадили от отрежьте
новости которые не приносят вам
возможности Оставьте себе новости
которые могут принести вам возможности
это к тому что как научиться
распознавать новости вот а пример до
Шану поступил звонок предложение его
триггернуло он понял что на этом можно
создать компанию классная идея И дальше
Поехали Акимат как обычно его кинул но
спасибо ему за то что он дал идею Угу
конечно видите идею даже Акимат может
давать идею причём идею it it ста ама
пось идею it стартапа даже Акимат может
давать Да может
потом получается у меня были два
партнёра в этом проекте и они связаны с
Тимуром турловым Ну как бы в его команде
можно сказать и мы получили предзаказ
начали выстраивать производство мате вот
цех как бы это программно-аппаратный
комплекс и Я предложил этим партнёрам Ну
мне честно мне было скучно дальше я
хотел что-то другое делать Я хотел
углубляться в искусственный интеллект в
этом проекте мы чуть-чуть применяли как
бы то есть эти алгоритмы искусственного
интелекта Ну чуть-чуть на уровне как бы
одного продукта А я хотел дальше в эту
сферу пойти и я им предложил меня купить
как бы они с Тимуром связаны деньги у
них точно есть я говорю купите меня отку
меня Я выйду я вам оставлю часть команды
а всю свою команду которая моя реально я
заберу с собой я им оставил три
разработчика и
вышел когда дожан говорит купите меня
Это не его лично конечно его компания
имеется в виду и Да ну мою долю Да твою
долю А вот смотри а вот э хорошо вот ты
обратился в нас в компанию миллиард
тенге - это условия по тендеру Но это же
или это предоплата это предзаказ Но от
одной компании только предзаказ А если
рынок собрать там хорошо предзаказ Но
эти деньги к тебе не падают сраз нетт
Нет нет нуно это это же индикатор Да ну
на что-то на что-то же надо было
развивать продукт Ну как бы у нас у нас
были инвестиции свои собственные мы сами
вложились с ребятами потому что у нас
уже операционная компания была которая
генерировать А ну вот как бы я им
предложил меня купить они меня
[музыка]
откупились чисто разработчики то есть
ребята которые занимаются разработкой
программного обеспечения и я узнал что в
академии наук одна команда математиков у
них Гран заканчивается и я узнал то что
эти ребята умеют хорошо заниматься
искусстве интеллектом обучать его и я
начал к ним выходить выдёргивать начал
по одного по одному там кофе попить там
поужинать и в какой-то момент я им
просто всем предложил Давайте всей
командой не подавайте на другой Грант
Приходите ко мне я вам зарплаты дабл
сделаю наша Академия наук шла Как раз на
пути к нобелевском этому
призу тут она посыпалась по математике
по математике причём резко посыпал Ясно
Да скорее всего так есть а хорошо но
финансирование финансировали вы сами Да
так У кого какие ещё опыты А да Для нас
Для меня УВО - это второй стартап вот да
вот откуда идея пришла начнём с этого Да
сам а проект то есть здесь Наверное у у
нас четыре кофаундер четыре со
основателя компании вот а я думаю что ну
я согласен что возможности вот какие-то
события наверное количество этих событий
создают а дальнейшем уже вот эти
возможности Вот потому что я от первого
стартапа отказался по определённым
причинам А и отказавшись от него Хотя я
хотел отчисляться с МГУ там с
университета и так далее но я отказался
от него Приехав в университет а у меня
была задача пойти попасть в консалтинг
Угу стратегический А в Москве
и Я участвовал Ну так как я на
математике it учился в Москве а мы
участвовали во всяких хакатона всяких
ивентах там хакатон - это э турнир по it
где команде даётся время чтобы
разработать решение от какой-то большой
компании обычно для студентов и мы
участвовали и увидели такую возможность
от манзи международная консалтинг
компания и Get такси Get - Это был
главный конкурент Яндекса в России вот
тоже миллиардный unicorn там компания
большая Вот мы
пришли участвовали в хакатоне нам гет
рассказал Все свои проблемы в такси Угу
и и Тогда для меня вот Первое знакомство
было с отраслью транспорта вот мы заняли
призовое место на этом хакатоне вот нас
позвали в Яндекс такси в гет всю команду
Вот Но мы по-моему только один человек
Пошёл Вот Но я взял эту задачу мне она
настолько понравилась что я взял её на
научную работу в университет убедил
своего научни Вот и оттуда у меня
начался такой research задача была в том
чтобы куда должен ехать водитель когда
он ещё не получил следующий заказ Угу
это будет особенно актуальная задача
Когда будут автономные Угу машины потому
что они непонятно то есть сейчас по
наити же едут а поеду туда по опыту А
куда будет ехать автономный вопрос Вот и
как раз этой задачей занимался полгода
она очень сложная была но потом Поти
такая алгоритмизация принятия решений о
том куда Да это индивидуальная Hit Map
вот Hit Map - это карта тепловая такая
куда у каждого должна быть своя чтобы не
было слишком много спроса там в одних
местах вот и потом я вообще не думал что
это будет как-то связано со стартапом
Угу На тот момент То есть у меня была
задача пойти в стратегический консалтинг
Вот и я в принципе закончил научную
работу а пошёл в международную компанию
стратегический консалтинг где я работал
2 года достиг там хороших результатов
вот тоже сформировал какие-то связи Для
себя определённые понимания А это уже в
Казахстане бы я вернулся в Казахстан А И
после этого встретил своего друга
а он ко мне пришёл в офис посоветоваться
А мы с ним вообще первые бизнес партнёры
в восьмом классе ещё были в восьмом
девятым мы бизнес разные делали с ним он
пришёл ко мне он чистый предприниматель
такой у него Футбольная академия одна из
успешных в Астане Я думал он про
футбольную Академию хочет
поговорить он пришёл и он мне говорит
Слушай Слушай у меня такая проблема Я в
общем раскачал свою свою футбольную
Академию за счёт того что у меня есть
развозка Угу И теперь развозка для меня
стала
геморроем с одной стороны с другой
стороны она для меня генерить клиентов
но я больше времени трачу на развозку
Хотя я вроде футбольной академией
занимаюсь и никому не могу делегировать
эту проблему Угу И у многих моих
знакомых друзей у кого есть такие кружки
всякие школы у них такая есть проблема И
это не организованный бизнес что думаешь
вообще и вот мы в принципе оттуда вот
идея зародилась мы начали Пилот с его
школы то есть начали смотреть он стали
партнёрами Я говорю давай это в
отдельный бизнес выведем и всё начали
Вот это делать подключать раз можно я
перебью
смотрите для меня вот в этой первой
части нашего подкаста я чу у каждого из
вас откуда пришли возможности так а вот
во втором стартапе ты говоришь друг
пришёл рассказал про свой бизнес и
рассказал про свою боль Да и идея
практически он даже тебе сказал что был
бы кто-то кто её решил Всё правильно да
то есть сам на толкнул Вот это тот
случай вот преимущество когда
возможности приходят через людей в том
что Обычно люди уже приходят с
предложением вот мне Много поступало
таких вещей на которых я заработал они
приходят говорят марла вот здесь
такая-то проблема Блин если бы ты смог
бы вот это выкупить а потом как-то от
нас забрать и так далее и Очень часто
было так что я у них выкупа развивал и
продавал то есть человек приносит и боль
и решение просто у него у самого нету
ресурсов решить эту боль ну людских в
основном ресурсов Это первый момент А
вот первый стартап который ты закрыл Что
за идея И откуда она пришла эта
возможность там очень просто онлайн
образование Угу 2012 год я онлайн
готовился к МГУ угу вот хотя она отлично
в одной из лучших государственных школ
учился в Астане и при этом Видел что у
мне не хватает там знаний физики а там
математики на том уровне на котором
нужно чтобы поступить Угу и занимался
онлайн и мне в принципе не нравился опыт
абсолютно и вот эта боль была то есть
это чисто с лично моей боли Я понял что
там сотни тысячи миллионы людей есть
Таких вот и я в принципе на первом курсе
вот в четырнадцатом году поступил я
сразу создал стартап Вот и начал вот
двигаться Почему закрыл потому что меня
переубеди один бизнесмен Я у него
работал ассистентом Ну как это не только
это наверное да но я наверное на тот
момент это был шестнадцатый год А я пил
много кому вот мне все отказывали Я пил
там половине Forbes пить это значит
рассказывать пытаться продавать
я ходил на форумы на всякие и так далее
просто как вот студент говорил что у
меня классная идея онлайн-образование
перспективное направление скоро оно
выстрелит но на тот момент никто не
верил в это вот все говорили
онлайн-образование - это очень маленький
рынок Вот и потом
я попал на работу Вот почему Да потому
что посчитал
что
это будет долго развиваться
онлайн-образование то что это ниша не
такая
большая показа а приведу Из своего опыта
Я уже где-то Я помню публиковал в своих
постах и говорил даже в интервью смысл
такой я в двадцатом году проанализировал
свои свой инвестиционный портфель за 10
лет назад Угу и А вернее до 2000 года за
20 лет назад а 10 лет я более подробно
анализировал а 20 лет в целом
ретроспективно чтобы понять Вообще на
чём я зарабатывал основную часть денег
и выяснилась любопытная статистика что
почти 80% не точно но почти 8 даже чуть
больше 80% своих денег я заработал
благодаря
сделкам то есть не операционной прибыли
А благодаря
сделкам и остальное плюс-минус
операционная прибыль там дивиденды и так
далее и так далее но больше получается
на сделках тогда я начал анализировать
откуда ко мне сделки приходили я
разобрал сво
и неуспешные у меня неуспешных Поверьте
мне вот так там у каждого хорошего врача
есть персональное кладбище Тае у каждого
хорошего инвестора есть персональное
кладбище денег вот я туда закопал очень
много вместе с
Фандера так вот
смотрите два камня в огород так закинул
сначала про больницу про врачей сну
потом проек который инвестировал вместе
СФУ напряглись Нет
смотрите я же ещё инвестировал в
Юта поэтому ну чтоб мода тоже понимал
там у меня персональное кладбище фаундер
тоже есть я как-то ребят возил которых я
инвестировал на балха Сея на хозяйство
привёз а там такая глухомань отдельный
остров и этот и там камыш Мы весь
вырезали там ещё куча земляных работ они
спрашивают кто это делал Я говорю ну там
есть ребята есть Ребята а потом Ребята в
отдельно пошли бане сидели говорит малан
колич мы поняли говорит вот э все работы
Адские говорит Могли сделать только рабы
рабов в современном мире нет а потом мы
подумали Почему вы нас привели сюда it
Фандера мы поняли тот кто не достигает
своих метрики показателей вы привозите
сюда и заставляете отрабатывать рабами я
вот примерно правильно Так вот смотрите
когда я анализировал свои факапы
неудачные стартапы А я выявил третий
источник
поступления возможностей но я его сильно
не рекламирую и людям не показываю я его
буду сегодня говорить как отрицательный
пример вот я говорил да возможности
приходят через людей самый шикарный
канал возможности когда приходят через
людей потому что это чья-то уже боль она
созревшая и человек приходит с решением
он даёт идею Как можно было бы её решить
просто у него у самого нет ресурсов Либо
денег либо времени либо людей второй
источник - это события Когда вы читаете
новости на этом на вот этой э на этих
возможностях Я заработал очень много
основную часть денег второй источник -
это события которое приходит мне через
новости я читаю новости и благодаря
новостям А я о думаю классная новость
надо разобраться Вот мой первый контракт
с правительством Узбекистана я прочитал
вообще в Интерфакс маленькая заметка
была что правительство Казахстана
заключило межправительственный договор с
Узбекистаном на 400 пшениц а я такой
блин Ну у них же нет столько пшеницы А я
был в теме и я пошёл эту гипотезу
отрабатывать и в конце закончилось тем
что контракт предоплата на 13 млн
долларов и я стартанул то есть это когда
ты вы берёте возможности из Новостей а
новости Естественно они отражают события
А события - это те изменения которые в
обществе и вот есть третий источник
возможности самый опасный и самый плохой
это когда вы сами придумываете вот когда
вы являетесь источником возможностей Я
заметил каждый раз когда я вижу
возможность думаю о классная возможность
я беру нахожу силу генерального
директора Даю деньги говорю давай газуй
вот эту ниша классная всегда косяк
99%
99% тех стартапов или бизнесов не только
в it сфере в it Я вообще чайник те
бизнеса Где я инициировал Где я
финансировал и говорил классная идея все
проваливались вот все проваливались
вот в этом плане я в отличие от Стива
Джобса полный
бездарь Стив Джобс
Он в чём его гениальность он создавал
возможности и сам их
реализовывался себе и думал что это
будет бизнес всегда это была потеря
денег вот второе подтверждение Я вижу
мадр у меня тоже такой кес первый кейс
когда он первый сам стартанул идея потом
выстрелил но он не угадал тайминг не в
нужное время вот знаете я читал одну
статью когда по-моему комбинатор которые
говорили что знаете идея airbnb И убера
была давно к нам говорит приходили
ребята но она выстрелила только когда
настало их время до этого куча ребят
обанкротились с похожими идеями Да
поэтому проблема отсюда возникает когда
вы создаёте идею начинаете
основная проблема происходит в том что
вы
влюбляет влюбляется в свою идею и это
проблема Ну это в моём случае было так и
вот мадр чуточку подтвердил Ну
[музыка]
да
давай
Вы же в моменте когда придумываете идею
Ну давайте я расскажу про то как у нас
появился ста вот как как у тебя идея
пришла или возможность у нас всё
достаточно просто смотри сколько ты
сделал таких компаний Потому что ты
сейчас знаешь Удачного расскажешь А
сколько у тебя кладбище своё Я пришёл
именно в it
с обычного предпринимательского опыта у
нас с супругой было достаточно много
проектов они были достаточно успешные мы
их с течением времени либо развивали
либо закрывали и вот крайне раз закрытие
было связано с тем что мы сейчас вот
готовим активно буквально через неделю
переезд уже в другую страну подожди
давай какая-то противоречивая фраза у
тебя получилась у нас было много
достаточно успешных проектов вот мы
открывали закрывали и вот недавно
закрыли закрывали Что это значит продали
с прибылью или просто закрыли Нет мы
выходили с операционных моментов и в
пользу тех проектов которые развивались
в моменте чуть лучше Вот по отношению ко
мне и к структуре ведения моего бизнеса
Наверное это было связано с платформой
со стартапом qt когда мы увидели больше
потенциала больше роста больше
возможностей Мы решили сосредоточить все
наши усилия в одном направлении ещё у
нас всего избавиться остального да да да
да но мы получается не закрывали их в
прямом смысле они косвенно существуют
без нас но мы уже не имеем НВ мы
вы мы вышли из операционки мы вышли из
операционки Не в плане продаж а в плане
какой-то будущей прибыли нашим же
клиентам то есть они зашли наперёд в
предоплата и мы просто оставили Этот
бизнес на ведение там всё связано с
арендным моментами вот у нас было кафе
там было арендный момент в плане
помещения вот мы больше ушли не в
сторону отдачи бизнеса как кафе а отдача
бизнеса как помещение у супруги была
фотостудия она буквально вот несколько
месяцев назад мы её тоже передали под
управление именно помещения идеи вот эти
откуда пришли фотостудия ка Да это всё
благодаря вот моей ашки мо в браке
порядка 19 вру 11 лет мне было 19 когда
мы вот
только
расписали изначально идея самой
платформы она появилась у нас вот самого
Стар сейчас до платформы Вот фотостуди
кафе это всё
а она придумала гори Давай этим займёмся
очень сильно меня дравит потому что так
лайфхак женитесь на
асну дальше Поехали при действу да Айс
лушка вот тот человек который меня очень
сильно дравит в моменте сейчас очень
сильно выручает по
каким-то домашним делам Потому что когда
ты пытаешься изменить ми Подожди подожди
ты уже очков передай слу набрал
хватит Явный подкол Да
я она меня дравит она мне это всё
понятно всё айслу Ты молодец продолжаем
дальше это всё-таки гемба подкаст и про
бизнес Смотри Вот она пришла с идеями Да
она идея это откуда взяла открыть
фотостудию и кафе меня сначала
интересует А у нас изначально вот у нас
ней так как мы начали ещё мы знаем друг
друга ещё там со времён там 17-1 лет А
изначально было желание делать что-то
своё не устраиваясь куда-то я никогда в
жизни не работал где-то по найму то есть
Первое это было решение
и оно пришло вот с течением с каким-то
нашим желанием иметь что-то своё иметь
какой-то доход который будет не зависеть
от твоих каких-то показателей с дети до
ше и ты можешь развивать большинство
людей сейчас с этим живут дальше Вот вот
практический
шаг у нас в моменте наверное открытия
нашего первого бизнеса был была очень
хорошая возможность очень девой
недвижимости в
аренду а то есть открыть фотостудию либо
кафе вам идея пришла от наличия
дешёвых помещений откуда у вас дешёвые
помещения появились А это был
2016 пятнадцатые года мы на тот момент
как раз развивали наш такой первый
небольшой опыт в it А и нам нужна была
фотостудия для записи роликов нам нужна
была очень-очень классное бетонное
лофтовая а лофтовые пространство которое
имело бы большие потолки и в Алматы была
проблема с этим вот мы как раз Понятно
Значит у вас была боль сначала боль
потом под эту боль айслу предложила
давайте мы сами свою фотостудию откроем
а кафе боль какая бы вот это как раз
История одного помещения у нас была
потребность в съёмке достаточно большого
количества роликов нам нужна была
локация бетонных локаций не было и мы
взяли у застройщиков черновом варианте
220 квадратов они были разделены на два
помещения по 110 и мы в одном
организовали классную локацию для студий
для съёмок по завершению которых мы
просто опубликовали в социальных сетях
то что ребят есть такая вот локация и мы
наверное хотим проверить гипотезу о том
что нужен ли Лофт в формате фотосъёмки и
с этого началась бизнес история левой
части помещения правая часть помещения
она э Долго пустова но в моменте Мы
подумали Почему бы не открыть кафе и не
кушать еду которую нам хочется понятно
не такая что пря но да да но тоже
история пришла с то есть Иногда я бы
сказал не иногда в большинстве случаев
бизнесмены так вот здесь где-то
генератор возможностей репу чешут вот
здесь вот так и некоторые Пальцем в небо
тыкают это тоже генератор возможностей
Вот кафе Это можно сказать И пальцем в
небо и ещ и посать затылок у меня ещ
одна небольшая отсылка в сторону ала
будет потому что сама по себе по себе
РПП он обязан ей так хорошо теперь какта
откуда идея появилась у меня есть лушка
она инфлюенсер и она как-то утром
подходит ко мне и говорит Слушай мне вот
нужен такой персональный сайт где можно
полностью всё настраивать добавлять Все
свои соцсети и желательно закрывать
сразу там сделки я говорю окей есть вот
небольшие аналоги Давай попробуем их Она
говорит пожалуйста настрой Я приду и
начну этим пользоваться я более
углубленно помню целый день произ учал
эту нишу понял что потенциал там очень
много и никто не связывает в конечном
функционале то что делает qtab никто не
даёт и я подумал скорее всего это вот то
настолько простое и поверхностное чем
можно заниматься и что может в
очень-очень короткой перспективе сделать
очень хорошие трекшн в плане денег и в
плане пользователей и наш самый первый
аккаунт который был зарегистрирован на
платформе он как раз принадлежит моей
супруге Айс и вот с этого началось она
начала пользоваться той платформой
которой мы создали её окружение и 100
200 500 первых пользователей это было
всё её окружение И это была полная
органика мы не занимались тем что
кому-то предлагали то что мы делаем
классно Сейчас минутку а источником
возможности
Потап тому успешному проекту которым
сейчас занимается мандат а выступила
супруга которая в свою очередь блогер и
она озвучила свою боль а видите вариант
когда возможность приходит через других
людей она приходит двумя способами
первый способ Когда вы ничего не дела
Как случае с маром приходит друг и
давайте давай я хочу посоветоваться и он
озвучивает свою боль и приходит идея
этим заниматься во втором случае это
когда мадат
сам проявляет инициативу и
думает то есть айслу дала свою идею
просто озвучила свою боль ада дальше
начал копать копать копать и понял что
это большая боль то есть вот очень важно
подметить смотрите в любом стартапе в
любом начале любого бизнеса самое
сложное - это найти идею самое сложное
найти идею которую можно монетизировать
и на которой можно зарабатывать Угу
потому что Вот все Ну 99% людей - это
чешут репу И пальцем в небо вот в этом
проблема Я хочу немного научить людей
смотреть а на возможности вообще на всё
по-другому смотрите Как можно научить
себя натренировать себя видеть
возможности ведь для того чтобы стартап
получился успешным нужно хорошие
возможность это значит кто-то клиент
какой-то клиент или много клиентов у
которых есть большие боли для этого
научите четыре вещи Вот я считаю четыре
вещи которые являются источником или
основой для успешного любого стартапа
первое научитесь видеть вещи по-другому
Вот люди смотрят на этот стакан видят
одно научитесь видеть по-другому вот
спрашиваете Например у кого-то что ты
видишь он говорит стакан с водой Вот как
раз вот то высказывание по поводу стакан
наполовину пуст наполовину полан это как
раз тот случай когда два разных человека
видит по-другому тот же са я могу видеть
вазу для цветов Да ты можешь представить
что блин классная ваза была бы для
маленьких для подснежников они маленькие
ваза для цветов кто-то может подумать
Блин так этим стака прибить можно то
есть хороший
инструмент и кто-то может сказать блин
классно хрустали и так далее То есть
научитесь видеть вещи по-другому и
события второе научитесь делать
по-другому
Вот те вещи которые люди обычно привычно
делают научитесь эти же вещи делать но
по-другому
третье научитесь видеть другое вот Глядя
на тот же стакан все видят одно а вы
научитесь видеть другое и четвёртое
научитесь делать другое люди вот
привычно Для решения проблемы Вот как в
случае с мадатов они привычно делают а
мадат посмотрел и понял что можно
сделать совсем другое Угу Угу И вот это
источники
четыре фильтра для того чтобы чётко
видеть возможности вы вставляете в свои
очки видеть по-другому делать по-другому
видеть другое делать другое у меня ещё
один драйвер
был в феврале двадцать второго года в
январе двадцать второго года Я очень
давно знаю Лёшу ли это
[музыка]
вот я с ним был партнёром кетони были
партнёрами и потом продали з Здорово
Алексей классный парень я в январе с ним
помню Зазу Я говорю Лёш есть вот такая
идея вот вроде бы ниша классная и вроде
бы мы набираем хороший трекшн и это всё
органикой он говорит Не фигня не полетит
И я такой ладно И мы начали это делать и
тот момент что он говорит Ну слушай
чувак Ну не полетит и не знаю в моём
случае сильно здрави меня А когда мы
летом открыли Сид Алёша ко мне позвонил
и Сид - это начальное финансирование
начальный ра вот да как раз при Сид А мы
как раз созвонились летом и Лёша уже
стал нашим инвестором м
что если человек негативит либо в первом
приближении говорит нет вот интересная
такая вещь про переговоры говорю если
человек говорит нет большинство 99%
людей думают что это конец разговора на
самом деле это начало разговора Потому
что когда вам отказали И сказали нет это
у вас есть веская причина спросить а
можно узнать А
почему А что вас не устроило сам продукт
условия
условия доставки рассрочка платежа что
конкретно устроила Когда вы начте
задавать уточняющие вопросы очень часто
тот человек который сказал Нет потом
говорит Да И вот это основная
особенность крутых продавцов когда они
получают Нет они этот нет воспринимают
положительно Мы же воспринимаем
отрицательно простые люди думают мне
сказали нет всё это значи коне разговора
самом вот полу
приме потом стал сам стал первым одним
из первых инвесторов да буквально прошло
3-4 месяца у нас были договорённости как
раз как вы и сказали Я уточнила Почему
нет и Лёша сказал ну потому что у этой
идеи там А нет достаточной скорости в в
наборе а пользователей есть допустим
конкуренты которые уже есть и которым
уже ну выгодно которыми уже пользоваться
в моменте сейчас этот конкурент имеет
8.500 пользователей по Казахстану у нас
32.000 мы это сделали с Апреля двадцать
третьего до вот момента сегодня Вот
классно конкурент 9 лет на рынке
конкурент да более 89 лет мы не будем
его озвучивать но он уже ле вот смотрите
это
таплин это то С чего вы к нам пришли вы
активно были пользователем этого сервиса
это тоже про боль имее если можно
подытожить мы вот развиваем один и тот
же стартап и глупо сейчас Бут
рассказывать эту же историю у меня нет
олуш Вот вот я хотел бы здесь просто
столько классных моментов было и тло
было куда-то влезть поэтому хотелось бы
подытожить мы вокруг до около ходили
одной темы которая наверное отвечает на
изначально поставленный вопрос как там
прийти к открытию стартапа Как найти
идею Да это боль это вот решение боли Я
учился на маркетолога и вот ты когда
открываешь книгу котлера Что такое
маркетинг хочешь понять и это
удовлетворение человеческих потребностей
если вкратце Мне кажется это понятие оно
применимо к в принципе определению
успешного бизнеса успешного стартапа тго
проекта без разницы если ты
удовлетворяет очень хорошо человеческую
потребность закрываешь то есть его боль
поэтому я бы посоветовал наверно молодым
бизнесменам Да и не только молодым
просто всем бизнесменам стартапера найти
какую-то Боль в какой-то нише которая
желательно вас бы самого привлекало
чтобы вы горели этим делом и попытаться
её решить Вот это во всех наших случаях
Изначально было так как у мадра когда он
пытался поступить в МГУ у него была боль
он не мог онлайн образованием там
заниматься чтобы нормально получить
знания и э через 10 лет сейчас Ну ему
тогда сказали тоже да вот этот момент
есть то что не верили там условно у нас
Ты же предлагал это как стартап тебе
сказали типа нет Это очень рынок
маленький по итогу через 10 лет онлайн
образование сейчас не знаю Нету наверное
человека кто кто онлайн Да не занимается
образованием как и инфлюенсеры так и
просто пользователи А это тоже кстати
говорит есть же декады мы вчера с тобой
обсуждали в в стартапах вообще есть
декада то есть 10 лет примерно Вот если
бы они бы продержались бы 10 лет то
сейчас бы они очень круто выстрелили бы
и тогда вместе с ними Скорее всего
кто-то тоже запускался может тоже Get
курс Не знаю какие-то ещё моменты просто
не знаю онлайн образования какие-то вот
такие прямо мастодонтов и они вот выжили
и сейчас они очень крутые в Америке
кстати декада там 5 лет ну недавно Я
читал статистику а до юникорн в основном
9 лет юникорн - это единорог Это если
уже стартап в миллиарды вы до миллиарда
которые дошли Вот они анализировали
миллиардные компании которые стали
миллиардные но вот эти Мы же думаем it
идея как в фильмах там идея чувак
запустил через полгода миллиардер нет в
среднем оказывается 9 лет вот и также я
просто со стороны сколько знаю модата
наблюдаю а мне кажется там второй фактор
- это вот тоже схоже с вашим с вашими че
четырьмя пунктами Кругозор научиться
смотреть на вещи по-разному А на тот
период ребята Уже побывали в Штатах и у
них Кругозор очень сильно вырос и Я
скорее всего уверен в том то что у них а
была боль в плане студии той же а нету
классной студии давай откроем у айслу
как у девушки было 100% была боль вот я
хочу как в США какую-то кафе вот такую
чтобы она была инстаграмная чтобы была
вот так чтобы было по иде вот так чтобы
такие завтраки были они тоже она тоже
закрывала свою боль поэтому тоже где-то
успешный проект был и также открылся наш
стартап исходя из боли я туда зашёл как
изначально Как инфлюенсер как человек
который хотел много же сейчас соцсетей
Блин очень много и тре появился и tiktok
и и WhatsApp ите и менеджер есть и
Instagram и YouTube и так далее и так
далее и так далее и где-то платформа где
ты что-то продаёшь очень много разных
платформ соцсетей где ты ведёшь свою
активность активную деятельность Угу и
хотелось бы куда-то всё это собрать вот
так вот к сожалению Да мы говорили о
конкурентах топли Ну не в очень красивом
формате это всё предоставлял и мы
сделали просто это круче вот есть у меня
друг все его наверное знают Расул
Абдуллаев министр маркетинга Казахстана
Вот он очень классно сказал на самом
деле А qt - это таплин на максималках
или топлинг который смог Вот это для
меня конечно Что такое прикольное потому
что таплин я очень давно знаю тоже как
бизнесмен им пользовался в цветочных
магазинах и так далее а вот qt сейчас
вырос очень сильно Как визуально это
очень классная визитная карточка
изначально была для меня как для блогера
А теперь я там ещё могу продавать и вы
там тоже продаёте уже свои пока Давай
пойдём дальше я хочу до конца Откуда
приходят возможности
дожан дожать эту тему сказать Откуда
приходит возможность Вот ты ты рассказал
по поводу
через ама пришло у тебя были неудачные
Да уменя бы в обратную сторону круг
Сейчас ещё раз вспомним неудачный и кто
был автором или кто Принс возможность
которая была неудачно сам
тоже я как знал я как знал Так у меня
тоже вот неудачные кейсы были как вы
говорите там всё должно было сойтись
была классная команда были деньги была
технология было иде идея крутая все
горели но не шло А проекты которые
начинались типа вот допустим церебрум Мы
начинали Мы думали Мы 200.000 потратим
что-то сделаем и на край мы просто это
подарим короче миру просто на Open
Source выложим все алгоритмы и всё Салам
алейкум Ну как бы проект до сих пор
живёт То есть я не знаю а в части
допустим насчёт боли я чуть-чуть не
соглашусь со всеми вами я считаю можно
делать любой проект вообще любой проект
если человек готов этим
лет СРО можно из любой сферы выжить
что-то крутое Ну может быть там
типографии не надо делать Да ну условно
Да в современном мире но практически
любую сферу можно развить потому что
куда нет кни везде что-то плохо дажа
Смотри чтобы не вводить людей в
заблуждение Почему мы обсуждаем про боли
и почему мы обсуждаем про то чтобы
фаундер должен
гореть мы сегодня обсуждаем про наиболее
гй ть который даёт большие шансы Понятно
Можно сейчас упереться нам всем и
улучшить iPad Но это будет улучшение Вот
такое А потрачены годы работы и
исследований и мы сделаем улучшение не
проблема мне есть вещи которые не
устраивают в Айпаде и Мы это устраним
сделаем но это не сопоставимый
результат Мы же здесь хотим дать людям
что чтобы за меньше усилия за меньше
усилия они получили что-то Что даёт им
результат с большей вероятностью то есть
боль когда ты находишь Боль это резко
увеличивает вероятность успешности
проекта Когда фаундер горит этим это
резко увеличивает вероятность успешности
проекта Поэтому в чём ценность вообще
эксперто в том что это люди которые
понаделали фака пов и говорят ребята
туда не ходи снег на голова упадёт сюда
не ходи там по башке получишь Дале вот
Наша задача предостеречь людей от этого
Артур у тебя в твоём случае Расскажи у
тебя были стартапы которые ты
инициировал или возможность которые
приходили от людей вот возьмём любую
сферу где ты успешно например ты блогер
Да вообще идея блогерства откуда пришла
Как ты сюда пришёл вообще как инфлюенсер
наверное в школе ещ у меня я не сдавал
НТ я защитил международный проект и у
меня было очень много
и я посмотрел на запад там снимали
какие-то прикольные видео и у меня было
много свободного времени я начал снимать
также То есть тут я наверное у меня
такого не было что вот если бы я чем-то
не горел бы я здесь вот соглашусь нужно
гореть да 100% тем чем ты занимаешься то
что любишь и делать это и у тебя в любом
случае что тогда получится может не
очень круто но получится Самое главное
чтобы тебе это нравилось вот у меня так
это получилось у меня не было К
сожалению таких вот неуспешных
классно вот смотрите классно мы сейчас
за столом разобрали возможности любого
бизнеса это не только it бизнес первое
очень важно Ну через что приходят
возможности через людей через события
новости и из вашей головы Вот Откуда
приходит Да но теперь Э для того чтобы
был любой бизнес успешным Это хорошо
найти боли людей по сути Вот люди они
приносят свои боли а второй способ
который Артур демонстрирует Если вы
просто Горите
чем-то пофиг на боли занимайтесь тем что
вы любите Вот это я всё время об этом
говорю во всех своих интервью что
занимайтесь любимым делом в конечном
итоге он может быть коммерчески не супер
будет успешным но во-первых у вас будет
всегда удовлетворённость ощущение
счастья первое второе Я не верю что он
будет неспешным е хорош
сказал успеха просто долго занимайтесь
одним делом если это дело ваше любимое
дыхалка в долгом периоде она полюбому
выстреливает Вот пример Артура он просто
Ему нравилось заниматься он начал
заниматься сколько лет ты уже
занимаешься де 9 лет ты уже ты миллиард
подписчиков дол было быть декада У меня
как раз да миллиард подписчиков у тебя
должно быть я вот Дожил до декады сейчас
вот миллиард подписчиков будет Вот 9 лет
занимается Многие же думают блогер это
вот вышел раз быстро Снимал и вот у тебя
получилось Поэтому конн или на
английском или настойчивость
настойчивость это очень важно И вот
любовь к делу как раз нужна для того
чтобы была настойчивость Если вы не
любите дело то у вас не будет
настойчивости вы просто сольётесь на
пути и может быть и очень часто кстати
люди сливаются Именно тогда вот прямо
перед взлётом очень часто хорошо Мы про
возможности поговорили Теперь давайте
поговорим как раз-таки про настойчивость
Аа вот
настойчивость когда остановиться вот
человек может быть настойчивый в чём-то
а там тупик и вот когда понять что там
тупик или там
возможность вот как вы думаете Давай
дожан я не знаю сложный вопрос сильно
Это очень сложный вопрос Ну типа когда
когда продолжать А когда становиться
можно как Осёл упереться идти А ну да Я
не знаю Вот честно не могу сказать
потому что очень долго если ты делаешь
допустим условно искуственный интеллект
в Казахстане то там 3-4 года тебя будут
сумасшедшим считать потому что во-первых
не было ни одного успешного кейса
во-вторых там Казахстан за всю историю
ни один проект медицинский не создал
который в де получил или ци сертификацию
типа даже к инвесторам когда идёшь к
казахстанским они могут над тобой
смеяться прямо до встречи а иностранные
инвестора вообще типа не воспринимают
тебя Ну то есть в какой-то момент ты
думаешь Блин я сумасшедший какой-то что
ли типа что я делаю и типа вот я не знаю
где этот предел я точно за этим пределом
короче да Так мне кажется Вопрос такой
больше кого-то философский немного он
внутри э вот тоже несёт вот этот момент
о том что если ты горишь делом и я бы
наверное здесь сказал бы нужно быть
голодным чтобы вот так вот идти Вот так
вот до конца сломя голову и вот яркий
пример вот здесь вот Человек сидит мадат
вот он слишком прямолинейно воспринял
фразу быть
голодным условно я сначала так косвенно
скажу как это выглядит а потом изза чего
прямолинейно привлек инвестиции после
прет раунда после первый нашей
инвестиции там тоже И вы были Лан
Калиевич много других наших
бизнес-ангелов В общем собрали около
полумиллиона долларов это везде Форси
Forbs там писал и так далее и так далее
и мне родственники начали писать Вау мой
мой родстве ты вообще мой племянник он
не Верт Всё мы можем ничего не делать
условно условно для кого-то это уже Стоп
да Но для нас это было только начало Мы
понимали что внутри сейчас всё нас ждёт
очень долгий ситра потом и так далее
ABCD и до конца а а мадат он постоянно
себя держит голодным То есть он он
понимает что это даже даже не начало
только вот это только какой-то зародыш и
он настолько эту фразу при манино
воспринял что он кушает сколько-то один
раз в день кушаешь Ты он он реально
прямолинейно супер воспринял э фразу что
в действительности хочет быть голодным
чтобы Да чтобы не как-то
[музыка]
не не только критическа реально в
голодном состоянии и особенно у человека
развивается творческая часть не
рациональная Вот ты можешь
концентрироваться на чём-то плохо Тебе
нужна Глюкоза чтобы концентрироваться а
для творческого мышления голодное
состояние супер помогает особенно когда
тебе стоит вопрос Где найти хавчик
вот там ты вообще Вот
давайте что думае
поводу
вот мы сегодня сейчас на советовали
нашим зрителям они говорят окей надо
заниматься любимым делом кто-то начнёт
заниматься любимым делом Независимо
деньги приносит не приносит и просто
упёрся мне сказали 10 лет переть в одном
направлении всё продал квартиры Маши всё
продал проду квартиры так
далее кто-то сказал что надо не любимым
делом заниматься надо сначала найти Боль
и туда оть вот хорошо Ну это же не все
100% отгадывают направлени я в этом
плане наверное не прям как таковой прям
советчик советчик мне совсем немного лет
мы Ну мы продали квартиру чтобы делать
то что мы чем чем мы сейчас занимаемся с
точки зрения наверное моих каких-то
внутренних мотиваций Ну это отчасти и
чувство голода но оно связано с моими
амбициями с тем где я хочу находиться
через год через 3 года через 5 лет чем я
хочу заниматься что вокруг меня должно
быть какие люди должны быть и это меня
дравит гораздо больше а в плане
Советов когда искать стоп Ну для себя
наверное как таковой Стоп А ну я не знаю
я каждое какое-то негативное каждый
какой-то негативный момент мы даже с
ребятами много часто обсуждаем поэтому
мы во-первых не умеем проигрывать
во-вторых Мы всегда каждый наш Как вы
говорили Нет это потенциал 99 Да и мы с
учётом наших амбиций наших целей наших
планов всегда Идём до конца и если
что-то делать то Ну делать это лучше
всех то есть ну No excuse Без
компромиссов там у меня есть знакомый и
мы как-то с ним разговаривали касательно
машин и Ну вот он классно выразился
когда мы разбирали Porsche Он сказал что
Porsche - Это только 911 и вот машина -
Это только только она и это должно быть
бескомпромиссно и мне понравилась Вот
его мотивация и его сила в словах То что
для у него есть одна машина и она
абсолютно
бескомпромиссная и она абсолютно
бескомпромиссно каким-то негативным
моментам нет или тому что что-то не
получается то есть ты настроен идти до
конца даже если это будет ошибка в любом
случае каждая ошибка Она потенциально
Как вы говорили несёт очень много
положительных верных решений и эти
ошибки они и дят нас так Мар когда Как
ты думаешь когда остановиться когда
продолжать Ну мне кажется у нас в этом
плане есть такой в стартапе наверное
релевантный опыт в стартапе есть такое
определение называется пиво когда Ты
поворачиваешь свою бизнес-модель почему
это происходит и Почему мне кажется у
нас довольно гибкая команда в этом плане
потому что ну то есть опять же здесь
есть интуиция Я думаю вот определение
вообще слова интуиция она у каждого то
есть вот я не знаю как её развивать это
наверное больше опыт подсказывает Да
людям там которые опять же и мудрее Да с
возрастом становятся но я думаю что
интуиция плюс насмотренность вот две
наверное важных таких вещи которые
позволяют тебе в моменте принять решение
вот Стоит ли дальше продолжать или нет и
это во всём Мне кажется в жизни так это
не только стартапов или бизнеса касается
не знаю девушку добиваешься например там
и тоже там она тебя отказывает
отказывает ты в какой-то момент чисто
интуиция блин получится или нет Ну вот
это мама твоя то же самое Да кто-то в
какой-то момент ты можешь например там
мама Да ты в какой-то момент Можешь
например там подумать что Всё Стоп А
хотя вот чуть-чуть и надо было дожать Да
вот ну то есть вот такие моменты и жини
ка получатся интуиция насмотренность и
Вера ещё получается да Да скорее всего
Вот таких три пункта которые который вот
позволяет принимать решения мы вот в
своём Например я вот часто вижу компании
стартапы которые или вообще в целом
ребята которые вот тоже бьются об
какую-то нишу которые вот ну сейчас не
очень тайминг например
Вот и вот исследование Y combinator про
которое вы говорили что тайминг - это
наверное Вот именно в бизнесе это
наверное вот в стартапах особенно в it
сфере это наверное номер один фактор
превышающий все остальные В какой момент
вы зашли со своей идее иногда вот
допустим лет пять назад я помню мы
обсуждали тему например замены кассиров
Казахстане вот ну кассиров мо может
заменить через искусственный интеллект
камеры и так далее а потом ты считаешь
математи
Да легче нанять сейчас просто кассира
живого потому что ну труд Не стоит так
дорого это только на большом масштабе
получится когда у тебя Art условно А на
таком Ну смысла нет вот и очень часто
такие моменты бывают у нас тоже такое
было что мы растили направление с так
как вот чтобы в автобус людей объединять
у нас основная фишка чтобы люди
использовали более рационально транспорт
То есть каждый день люди путешествуют на
работу и на разных такси на разных
машинах
а кому-то общественный транспорт забитый
полностью он неудобен Давайте их
объединять в микроавтобусы чтобы они
удобно все с разных компаний ездили на
них как частный общественный транспорт и
так как у нас в начале было мало
пользователей мы использовали легковые
машины и мы ещё начали водителей именно
женщин нанимать Вот это вообще сделали
водители женщины потому что тоже нашли
боль но я на этом не буду Остана но суть
В чём у нас в прошлом году был было
где-то 2.500 водителей женщин именно
которые работали у нас и у нас было
38.000 скачиваний мы вот запустили там
такси для женщин Хай Всё Всё вокруг и
тут через 2 месяца мы принимаем решение
что мы занимаемся микроавтобусами Угу И
нам пришлось отрубить Вот то направление
и столько хейта было столько мы потеряли
юзеров и это было вот такое волевое
сложное решение А почему вы приняли
решение такое решение было принято по
той причине что А мы поняли что продукт
оказывается для легковых и для автобусов
разный с точки зрения it во-первых А
во-вторых вообще с точки зрения
процессов это разные люди разные
пользователи разные аудитории Да мы
можем год здесь закопать Да мы можем
потом вот этот э там э Женское такси
например продать куда-то там в в Exit
какой-то сделать но это не
масштабируемая история нам глобальном
рынке вот мы в какой-то момент это
поняли мадр смотри Спасибо большое
ребята вот мы сейчас обсуждаем как раз
тему вы пошли в одном направлении когда
остановиться когда не остановиться
а очень важный Это вопрос на самом деле
и у многих это возникает упереться и
делать либо остановиться и так далее А я
поделюсь вам вообще своим опытом Я
понимаю так вещь в целом Так что в
начале Вы должны базово для себя принять
самое главное решение Вы готовы
заниматься бизнесом или нет Когда вы
принимаете решение это первое главное
решение которое не зависит от нише ни от
чего второе это нужно определиться со
своим намерением намерение самое главное
Если ваше намерение заработать денег
срубить бабла скорее всего у вас всегда
будут факапы
а намерение должно быть решить
бо людей то есть полное погружение в
тему Для того чтобы решить боль людей
деньги придут потом как Побочный продукт
решение этой проблемы поэтому второе это
должно быть намерение третье должна быть
вера в то что у вас получится и потому
что если у вас не будет Веры вы не
привлек себе команду вы не поведёте за
собой за вами люди не пойдут за зарплату
просто люди не готовы идти они готовы ид
за смыслами ког го представляете мы
будем менять мир мы будем Вот это
улучшать Мы людям создадим комфортную
обстановку если это ресторан или
атмосферу мы не кофе продаём мы продаём
атмосферу и так далее поэтому это третья
Вера и после этого вы выбираете нишу
которая вам нравится и идёте в этом
направлении
теперь как здесь остановиться Вопрос вот
в чём стоит Когда вы идёте в правильном
направлении если у вас правильное
намерение и вы выбрали правильно
направление в которое вы действительно
любите то как правило первое знаки будут
подтверждать что вы на правильном
направлении у вас будет появляться
откуда-то специалисты люди Вам будут
помогать другие люди как-то всё начнёт
складываться в вашу
пользу поэтому будьте внимательны К
знакам первый момент второй момент у вас
будет обязательно появлятся какие-то
препятствия и люди которые будут
говорить не полетит не пойдёт и так
далее и по этому поводу я очень часто
говорю вы знаете препятствие Что такое
препятствия и проблемы это на самом деле
специальный механизм который отсекают
человека от успеха в этом
направлении если это не твоё направление
Если ты не любишь Если у тебя мало Веры
то ты развернётся при первом нет и
уйдёшь А если ты упора ты идёшь то
проблемы отпадут это я часто привожу
пример с боксом Если ты любишь бокс то
Ты понимаешь что получать каждый день по
морде - Это норм и Твоя цель стать
чемпионом мира и не получать по морде а
бить по морде А если ты это не любишь то
ты каждый день будешь получать поро и
потом будешь приходить думаешь Ну
неужели я всю жизнь буду получать поже
Да нафиг мне нужно из-за этого ты плохо
тренируешься из-за этого ещё больше
получаешь поже и ты бросаешь и всё Ты
тебя отсекли от успеха в этом
направлении и теперь отличие мышлении
смотрите тот человек который любит бокс
и тот человек который не любит бокс тот
который не любит бокс он преувеличивает
проблемы и видит даже мелкие проблемы а
тот который любит бокс он преуменьшать
проблемы и не видит кучу мелких проблем
но видит сильно крупно
цель и вот здесь как раз-таки Вера Если
ты веришь и у тебя хорошее намерение то
ты как
правило будешь видеть возможности а не
проблемы потому что это тот случай когда
ты в любом направлении идёшь то ты
начинаешь видеть возможности которые
перед тобой открывают новые двери и
очень важно понимать видите А как кто
настраивает этот фильтр это ваше
намерение и ваша Вера и ваша любовь к
этому делу оно всё время открывает новые
возможности и тебя по пути корректируют
говорят вот ты идёшь сюда говорит левее
возьми левее Здесь слишком это вот можно
вот так то же самоя цель ты держишь цель
в голове и можешь левее правее таким
образом Это я часто говорю
а такой момент ошибка многих бизнесменов
в том что они планируют А своё движение
от себя к цели А надо планировать от
цели к себе вы берёте цель потом вы
пишете Какой последний шаг Вы должны
были сделать перед целью А какой
предыдущий предыдущий предыдущий Почему
люди так не делают
Потому что почему люди планируют от себя
Потому что они привыкли планировать от
своих ресурсов они говорят Ну у меня
есть квартира Я продам У меня столько
денег Ну как я туда могу Как я могу
поставить такие цели если у меня ресурс
такие но проблема и хитрость этого мира
в том что когда ты начинаешь двигаться в
сторону большой
цели ресурсы
появляются Вот ты пошёл в гору взял
самую большую вершину и идёшь смотришь
ягоды поел ягоды а ты еду с собой не
взял дальше идёшь раз грибы появились
идёшь ещё что-то то есть ресурсы это
появляются по ходу на этом уровне на
котором ты сейчас находишься ресурсов
нету они ровно столько сколько тебе
нужно чтобы достичь маленькую цель но
когда ты ставишь большую цель и
декомпозировать
ты начинаешь идти в этом направлении а
дорожка сама начинает перед тобой
стелиться А это возможно если ты веришь
если ты не веришь Ты никогда не пойдёшь
против логики потому что Вера и логика
они противоречат логика говорит Куда ты
прёшь у нас ресурсов не хватит не надо
остановись а Вера говорит Будет день
будет
хлеб иди вперёд и вот это Тонкая грань
мы мы должны понимать что весь успех
деньги всё приходит через Всевышнего
и в Библии даже говорится и в исламе
тоже есть такое а м а просите и дано вам
будет по вашей
Вере Если вы будете иметь Веру горчичное
зерно Вы можете двигать
горы проблема же наших людей в том что
мы не верим мы сами не верим в свои цели
когда у тебя есть стошка баксов ты
ставишь цели которые можно достичь
тушкой баксов ты не веришь во Всевышнего
Ты веришь в свои ресурсы и в себя и
говори Я добьюсь потому что Вот мои
ресурсы Вот мои действия и так далее ты
не веришь соответственно как ты
достигнешь больших успехов
поэтому никогда не останавливайтесь в
том что в чём вы верите если у вас
хорошее намерение и то в чём вы любите
вас дорожка сама выведет не просто
продолжайте Вы можете менять отрасли вот
то что
говори чтобы до того как любой стартап
находит идею на котором он уже
выстреливает он должен сделать
три-четыре Пит поинта не должен а в
среднем делать три-четыре пиво поинта
пиво поит - это полная смена стратегии а
иногда бывает вообще начал там
заниматься автоматизацией каблуков
женских условно Я прикалываюсь такой А
может Хорошая идея Кто
знает а а в
конце выстреливает Там что делает
подкрылки для космических аппаратов
понимаете ГВ идея Вот поэтому я как
инвестор всегда смотрю Я не смотрю на
идею Я смотрю на команду Я смотрю на
лидера готов ли он идти до конца вообще
в этом направлении не в производстве
каблуков А вообще в целом направлени
стартапов направлени там создания
бизнеса и так далее Вот это на самом
деле я считаю
Ключевое понимать если вы у вас
появляется мысль остановиться значит не
ваша тема если у вас такой мысль даже не
появляется Просто даже не надо вам
говорить и иди до конца ты и так будешь
идти до конца и это вопрос больше
наверное Веры веры в то что ты делаешь
веры в то что ты добьёшься вера в то что
это нужно людям э и благодаря этому ты
видишь больше возможностей нежели больше
нежели препятствия продолжим Давайте
вопрос о том когда идти до конца когда
не идти до конца рассмотрели хорошо У
вас есть идея прили возможности вы
запустили и так далее теперь как создать
команду или можно без команды вообще
вопрос команды это достаточно большой
вопрос многие путают думают команда -
это коллектив сразу скажу определение
коллектив - это те люди которые
выполняют функциональные обязанности за
деньги за зарплату а команда - это те
люди которые готовы выполнять больше чем
их функциональные обязанности за те же
самые деньги а Порой даже без денег
потому что они говорят той же самой идее
расскажите свои свой опыт как вы
работали с командой Как откуда она
вообще появилась Где их искать вообще
это рекрутинговое агентство их прит или
кто давайте поехали Ну вот я рассказал
то что мы с академией наук у них Грант
заканчивался я всю команду по сути 2 и
зарплаты им сделал и они пришли комне
кони
врата
де они пришли за идеей Мне кажется то
есть я им сказал мы но это была моя
ошибка я говорил Мне вообще плевать на
науку мы будем делать из A из математики
бизнес я им так говорил и будем идти
далеко ну типа сразу на мир будем в
итоге мы сейчас очень много науки делаем
весь мой как бы всё моё благосостояние
зависит от науки то есть всё что я
говорил это чушь Короче всё равно то
есть види совпало две
Первая это то что ты дал хорошую большую
большая иде ради которой они готовы уйти
с академи а второе ты ударил в их боль
их низкая зарплата надоело они говорят
Блин мы слишком умные для того чтобы
получать такую маленькую зарплату надо
из математики делать бизнес перешли к
тебе так поэтому Давайте заметку первое
люди крутые люди приходят под идею
абсолютно и
плюс как Выра есть я для
поня
из человек будет где-то условно человек
за которыми не надо их ими не надо
управлять им не нужны должностные
инструкции им не нужна структура
оргструктура им ничего не нужно они
будут
фоми им даже в принципе Дава Да им даже
как-то какую-то там корпоративную
культуру не надо Навязывать она сама
создаётся ими Я понял что держаться за
таких
Люде вопрос найма категорически допустим
у нас мы вообще не берём резюме ников мы
не берём допустим людей которые там у
них идеальная резюме нам плевать на
образование Угу мы смотрим Ну мы очень
смотрим на математику на понимание
Ребята это основатель
компании по искусственному интеллекту
говорит что плевать на образование Не ну
как бы да может я утрирую но в плане
утрируешь сейчас образование такое
просто ко мне очень много людей
приходило нет даже с самым крутым
образованием там условно самые топовые
ВУЗы но они перфор хуже чем ребята
которые там условно мехмат НГУ закончили
в казахстанский Фил они блин наши ребята
математики лучше Нет я иду пример то что
казахстанский
даже топовые мировые узы понимаешь да и
Ну первое то что мы перестали смотреть
на резюме очень сильно смотрим на личные
качества человека прям для меня это
Ключевое я раньше не понимал Почему
допустим люди вот как вы опытные когда
проводят бедова они говорят где ты
родился там какая у тебя
семья в какой школе учился там что
пережил условно в школе ну такие короче
вообще не задают вопрос там хорошо ты ли
знаешь xel там Умеешь ли ты выстраивать
какие-то модели математические прогнозы
вот типа я тогда не понимал когда Вот
раньше был молодой а сейчас я понимаю
сейчас у меня все интервью именно за
жизнь Короче я вообще не спрашиваю не
про скилы ничего То есть для меня важно
если человек подходит как бы как как
человек к нам он точно найдёт себе
применение и он точно принесёт ценность
потому что я точно знаю
что я сам я ничего не могу сделать сам
команда это самое главное
класс Артур Я думаю мы с Мадам да можем
про нашу историю
Давай
изначально в плане моего кофаундер у нас
е есть Наш кофаундер третий человек в
компании собран я его знаю на натяжение
16 лет и он всегда был в it если у меня
всего девять классов и нет ни высшего
образования ни средне специального то он
полностью у тебя девять классов и больше
церковно-приходской школы девять классов
смотри реб один основатель одного из
крупней успешного стартапа в Казахстане
it компании девять классов образования
девять классов университета Нет нету Вот
и спокойно в этом признаюсь ничего
страшного в этом нет мы просто упёрлись
что вот всё решает образование это
кстати большой миф люди строят так
лесенку в голове вот закончил школу надо
Хороший учиться потом университет потом
устроюсь в жизни нормально вообще Не
коррелирует
а я с ним знаком Достаточно давно мы с
ним познакомились в тренажёрном зале
когда-то вместе занимались а потом у нас
были совместные тоже небольшие такие
подработки в формате фриланса это вот
тот человек который показал мне что
такое код Там первые первые какие-то
совместные проекты мы там делали одно
время запуск сайтов рекламу это ещё там
в начале десятых годов а второй человек
который поверил в продукт это был Артур
Артур был одним из самых наших первых
крупных инфлюенсеров которые пришли к
нам Вот с точки зрения своей какой-то
личной боли он вначале пользовался
платформой и потом с нашей стороны
предложило поступило предложение к нему
Я хотел бы заметить что не Артур
нуждался в нас а мы в моменте всегда
нуждались в нём и по сей день и с учётом
там будущего его вклад вот он там
говорит я там всего лишь мёл ты не всего
лишь мёл ты полноценный сооснователь и
ты делаешь гораздо больше я здесь
благодаря тебе всё всё на Каспер с точки
зрения зачёт да да за перед алу
отчитался перед оной то отчитался Да
вообще ты крутой Артура Я просто ажана я
просто должен был упомянуть не альжан
второй человек на самом деле я третий у
меня на ножики третье число Отметь тоже
Аль Да альжан сделал большую часть
работы по платформе когда она была
только идеей мы вместе с ним вдвоём А
первые 0% того что сейчас есть делали
вдвоём Вообще никого не было потом
появился Артур Нас было трое а а с
учётом найма коллектива у нас история
сложилась Смотри сейчас коллектив не
интересует пока интересует команда это
всё команда у нас нет ребят которы как
появился он с неба упал как он
появился познакомился 16 лет назад в
тренажёрном зале не не альжан а Артура
го я от боли пришёл Кстати мне нужна
была студия Я пришёл мне нужна была
крутая студия и я все в Алмате
перекопать ж искал очень долго долго
долго и вот нашёл её очень крутую и был
вот посленовогодний период всё закрыто я
как-то как-то нахожу телефон звоню он
говорит я в Китае я ну вся вся команда
моя говорит на студии Они все в отпуске
мы не сможем открыть Я говорю у меня в
этот день только вот тогда я могу снять
потому что там вот актёры приезжают
уезжают там больше другого нету времени
пожалуйста что-то что-то начинаю Про
себя рассказывать просто вот чтобы
что-то получилось и он понимает у него
был плохой опыт с инфлюенсерами и он
понимает что ладно я ещё раз поверю
инфлюенсер попробую Может про ТП
расскажу может он будет пользователю
может что-то из этого получится Он
говорит Хорошо я приеду с Китая ради
тебя говорит открою тебе студию ты там
отнимешь что тебе нужно я приеду в Ново
в отпуск Он с женой там с дочкой я
приеду но ты меня выслушаешь говорит я
говорю хорошо и всё Мы с ним созвонились
Он мне так рассказал потом в жизни ещё
ра сказал Я говорю Вау как это круто
говорю вы капец боле закрываете
инфлюенсеров давайте я буду пользоваться
Давайте что-то делать я вам потом начал
приводить Я короче изначально был как
этот Агент как сутенёр стартапов ский я
приводил других вот так
вот интересно получается возможность как
пришла получается у тебя была боль ты
искал студию потом Мада тебе рассказал и
ты сразу ухвати увидел да да да ну
просто как пользователь и потом он уже
за какие-то вот такие агентские моменты
я уже просто как раз-таки был не
командой а коллективом просто там за
какие-то за какую-то минимальную
заработную плату просто приводил вот так
вот процент какой-то был а потом уже
настолько всё выросло что да это
полноценный партнёр семь кофаундер и
доля все дела Угу То есть у тебя
органично получается команду собралась
да да да И вот ребята которые сейчас у
нас до
сейчас у нас в коллективе Но они в
команде они у нас появились с точки
зрения вот допустим четвёртый человек в
коллективе его зовут айден анли он
делает очень классные вижуал он отвечает
за продукт и дизайн он вообще Работал в
Москве в kpmg получал зарплату там
порядка 10 000 долларов и я его сканти к
себе Первые 4 месяца он получал 300.000
тенге я ещё умудрялся задерживать ему
выплаты этой суммы Он поверил в то что
мы делаем и поверил в потенциал того что
идея может классно масштабироваться
момент у нас не было никаких комит
никаких там договорённостей об
инвестициях Я просто говорю У нас есть
задача сделать это лучше лучше того что
есть на рынке ребята которые сейчас
приходят к нам у нас была проблема Я
помню мы очень сильно нуждались в
масштабировании как раз когда вот начали
поступать первые предложения об
инвестициях мы думаем Ну всё Пора значит
вот из четырёх Человек становиться
немного там побольше А мы не могли снти
очень-очень классных специалистов мы
писали им на LinkedIn мы писали им там и
в какие-то личные моменты переписок нам
советовали ребят ну ни у кого желания
особо не было работать в стартапе я
познакомился с Пиа специалистом в
Казахстане Александр лихман я говорю вот
Саш у нас есть такая проблема что бы ты
посоветовал вот с точки зрения найма и
Саша мне сказал у тебя есть личный бренд
тебя как Фандера знают Просто сделай
Клич со своих личных страниц я
опубликовал в линкедине в Инстаграме и в
Фейсбуке и мы за первый день получили 32
заявки и с них мы снти наших первых трёх
очень сильных
пой день вот смотрите ребята вот яркий
кейс
получается Когда Вы начинаете делать
свой бизнес Обязательно должна быть идея
А ту боль которую вы решаете намерение
Вера и идея после этого вы собираете
людей как коллектив платите зарплату Но
к вам как правило Вы должны в коллектив
уже набирать людей которые верят в эту
идею который вот он с kpmg 10.000
долларов получал
за 300 те рабо то есть изначально вы
берте в коллектив людей которые
изначально вет в эту идею после этого из
них кто сильно вовлечен вы
вытягиватель Я говорю определённо у
первого костка из ми человек есть опцион
с компаниями потому что я понимаю что с
первой восьмёркой я буду
взаимодействовать очень долго и у нас
Могу ли
ято есть такая философия У меня лично
первая восьмёрка я с ней буду очень
долго дай Бог несколько там не знаю
декад и у всех есть опцион в компании от
06 до п и наверное с моей точки зрения
это было сделано ради того чтобы через 5
лет в моём окружении были только
миллионеры Я очень Верю в то что мы
делаем и очень Верю в то что даже вот
эти вот минимальные процентные опционы
которые есть у сотрудников приведут их к
достатку и мой круг общения будет
сть крутится вокруг ребят которые имеют
достаток и которые могут называть там
себя
миллионерами вот у нас такая Классно Вот
теперь ещё такой момент я наверняка
думаю Наверняка у зрителей возникает ещё
вопрос Вот у тебя де классов образования
А ты так очень
хорошо формулирует свои мысли логика
изложение язык Ты читаешь или Откуда
это
ячи сейчас нет достаточно большого
количества времени чтобы набирать
какие-то объёмы в плане книг но в
последние моменты времени в последние
несколько недель это в основном статьи И
я очень сильно стараюсь читать что-то Ну
вот плюс около it Но с другой стороны я
очень много времени посвящаю общению с
людьми которыми с которыми можно
обогатиться просто за счёт вот этого вот
мимолётного общения вот тот же пример
Бахт не язов всё случилось вся сдел ми
чное знакомство оно было через нашего
азера базова и то время те 5 минут 3
минуты 4 минуты которые мы вместе
объединяясь там как-то проводим в жизни
Они для меня гораздо ценнее сейчас чем
какие-то Наверное более длительные
отрезки времени там уделённое какому-то
какой-то формате какому-то формату
чтения допустим книги Ну я конечно приду
к этому
яза в ТМ
саморазвитии Импакт или влияние
оказывает книги общение с хорошими
людьми умными или что это люди это люди
То есть общение да да И это люди и это
именно сегментация людей то есть Я
конечно могу открыто общаться со всеми и
Ну мне интересно Давать какой-то фидбек
или что-то узнавать Но по большей части
я очень эгоистично отношусь к своему
кругу именно людей я стараюсь стремиться
к тем ради Ну в общении с которыми я
получаю какой-то фидбек в свою сторону
То есть я стараюсь Уделять больше
времени тем людям которые знают больше
меня могут рассказать чему-то обучить и
чаще всего это поколение старше меня
намного старше меня вот лайфхак ребята
смотрите человек девять классов закончил
по его речи не скажет что девять классов
Это первое Второе основал компанию
успешно развивается всё классно всё
равно я не верю в историю что вот девять
классов закончил и это настолько крутые
девять классов Кстати какую школу
закончил а с четвёртая гимназия Она
находится в районе с четвёртую гимназию
не закончил а представляете если бы он
закончил её так вот я не верю в эту
историю что человек вот девять классов
окончил и на этом идёт просто
чувствуется что есть огромный
наработанный багаж а эрудиция знания и
так далее и в данном случае вот мадат
рассказал что окружение окружение
которое круче его то есть которое его
тянет которое заставляет развиваться
думать по-другому и так далее поэтому
это вам как лайфхак даже для тех
Наверняка у кого-то есть дети которые
школу не закончили Либо вы сами что-то
не закончили и комплексуй по этому
поводу можно идти по пути читать книги
а покупать курсы и развиваться там это
тоже классная идея но Одно из самых
крутых вещей - это нетворкинг правильные
люди связи среда
общения людей которые круче вас Если вы
в комнате самые умные того Вы не там
находитесь насчёт команды поехали да я я
во-первых здесь бы чуть-чуть поспорил
насчёт вот ну некоторых моментов да то
есть по поводу там позиционирования
наверное там обучения вот то что до
сказал В целом за жизнь то что общение
Да на интервью это так Но для нас всё
равно каким-то для меня лично базовым
критерием является и образование в том
числе Наверно я бы не стал отсекать
топовые
университеты Да топовые школы даже грубо
говоря там государственные школы Там
рфмш ктл и так далее Потому что эти
школы в принципе то есть то есть человек
стремится и в КТ очень много простых
ребят которые смогли туда попасть Это
первый фильтр в жизни по идее Вот ты у
каждого разные события конечно кого-то
жизнь принуждает работать у не нет
возможности там где-то учиться и таких
очень много у нас Но есть те кто живут
там в городе условно Да там и в принципе
вот это хочется выяснить на интервью
всегда понять какая предыстория если
предыстория такая что это там Городская
среда и так далее каких-то жизненных
челленджей сильных не было то человек
должен был запер грубо говоря то есть
хорошо какую-то крутую школу закончить
при наборе команды ты на образование
Смотри я смотр Я смотрю на школу очень
важно смотрю на Университет потому что я
считаю что это фильтры жизненные вот
стой человек О чём он думал вот в то
время да это как для меня вот в голове
первые фильтры плюс Расскажи опыт свой
командой Откуда она пришла вот да вот
допустим но но вот здесь опять же то что
вот откуда она пришла здесь я наверное
соглашусь то что всё все результаты
Всевышний нам даёт я в этом неоднократно
убеждаюсь допустим и и намерение вот я
мы в двадцатом году вот расулом котору
сегодня как раз речь Артур поднимал в
том числе мы делали благотворительный
проект туба называется вот амбассадором
Хабиб Нурмагомедов является армано
литров мы делали вообще с ребятами там с
Дагестана вот хотели просто во время
ковида сделать платформу удобную чтобы
можно было мошенников сбегать собрали
хорошие фонды дара там вот фонды
профессионалов и объединили всех на
платформе и сделали
краудфандингу Я вообще вот для меня это
было чисто вот сделать какую-то пользу
для людей вообще ноль монетизации только
мым свои деньги как бы на Казахстан
вкладывали я молчу про ребят Вот там
тоже там Братьев с Дагестана которые
огромные ресурсы туда вкладывают просто
чтобы помогать Угу включая Хабиба
миллионы долларов он вкладывает в это
всё и мы помогали запуском в Казахстане
к чему это привело в итоге как это
повлияло там на стартап мы я
познакомился с огромным количеством
крутых ребят в рамках этого
благотворительного проекта и в дцать
первом году когда я начинал стартап я
разговаривал с одним из ребят с которым
я познакомился в рамках этого проекта мы
вместе делали вот благотворительную
платформу и в итоге он стал кофаундер
Этот человек Он он учился в МГУ тоже на
мехмате он работал в Яндексе 3 года
потом работал в Фейсбуке в Лондоне 4
года и вот как раз в д первом году Он
уходил в Twitter и в Лондоне и мы вот с
ним соз телефон Он говорит Слушай я с
Фейсбука ушёл Вот и сейчас вот в
Твиттере у меня много времени свободного
появилось Вот и вообще какие идеи есть
может быть что-нибудь сделаем интересное
я ему начал рассказывать про то что мы
начали делать вот э развозки то что есть
проблема Вот его наверное вот если
говорить про него Его муар зовут вообще
вот он второй человек компании Он третий
Потому что первый - это вот второй был я
по сути потому что был Муса Угу э
который вот ко мне пришёл а это мой
Однокласс - Он на год старше старше меня
учился в школе мы с ним в школе бизнес
делали вот я говорил вот то есть первый
кофаундер он мы с ним в школе учились
Угу Вот были лидерами в школе и он и я
там в каких-то направлениях Да разных
Вот и мы вместе общались дружили в школе
вот это вот первый случай так скажем
второй это вот э там уар наверное это
вот про э знакомство через
благотворительный проект it это сио наш
да И вот четвёртый у нас кофр есть он
вообще встречался с сестрой Мусы
сестрёнкой Мусы То есть это по сути мош
сказать я не знаю родственник Как это То
есть все эти хороши Да наверное Ну то
есть в рекрутинговое агентство вы не
обращались нет В вашем случае
рекрутинговое агентства тоже не было Ну
так получилось что это мы сами были же
не было так я вот здесь подытожить
хотелось бы а то у нас этот как будто бы
призыв был Да я вот поддерживаю тоже
Мади этот условно сейчас кто-то
посмотрит молодой в школе там учится
парень придёт домой мам всё марна сказал
Можно не учиться я после девятого ухожу
да то есть оно нужно в любом случае
какое-то до образование Просто бывает
самородки Да у кого-то получается а у
кого-то может не получиться и потом
чтобы не обвиняли это классный фильтр
как Мади сказал
обучение образование вообще и оно же вот
мы как вот мы же когда нанимаем условно
кого-то Мы же смотрим на его действия
дальнейшее мы от него требуем действие а
действие как формируется изначально от
взгляда от взгляда там идёт установка
вот этот взгляд установка оно как раз
таки формируется благодаря окружению
нетворкингу которое где ты обучаешься
там в школе в университете и так далее
потом уже идёт самооценка условно
чувство реакция и действие шестое по
пунктам идт поэтому Да не не не Примите
наши высказывания как призыв действи у
ещ всё мне кажется от философии компании
зависит например в амазоне первые
по-моему 3 и 5 лет бес нанимал только
людей у которых высокий sit скор в школе
то есть это
ЕНТ то есть люди даже у которых в яху
там человек работал 10 лет там есть вот
фильм про Amazon он говорит меня когда
нанимали у меня спросили результат ЕНТ А
я уже 10 лет работаю в технологическом
технологической компании я такой на
интервью такой не могу вспомнить какой у
меня результат а они набирали только там
Вот таких гиков то есть задротов они
нанимали таких прям у которых всё прям
супер там перформанс и так далее это вот
философия такая с другой стороны понятно
что по сути Вот вот этот строчка она
зачастую влияет только на то чтобы ты
попал на резюме на интервью Угу А вот на
интервью Ты уже проявляешь уже личные
качества там Твои навыки реальные потому
что можно получить ние образования А я
абсолютно согласен с тем что образование
важно и нужно как фильтр потому что
образование даёт дисциплину образование
даёт логику образование даёт это
социальные навыки общение решение
проблем Первая любовь драка понятия и
так далее То есть умение кооперироваться
с кем-то дружить с кем-то делать
совместные проекты какие-то и так далее
Это тоже даёт школа не в рамках
официальной программы а вот в школе же
помимо уроков есть ещё куча общения
поэтому это очень-очень важный а этап
формирования вообще личности а Поэтому
если говорить в целом про образование Я
очень а сильно верю в образование и Да я
за образование но не предметное то есть
не так чтобы там а не обязательно химию
узнать так глубоко как мы это детей
пичка не обязательно физику знать так
глубоко как мы это делаем геометрия
алгебра Я например ни разу в жизни не
применял и даже не разбираюсь Что такое
косинус синус тангенс котангенс и там
извлечение корней Я просто название знаю
А как это физически делать не знаю я в
жизни пользовался калькулятором четыре
кнопки плюс-минус там умножить делить
всё ну и проценты вычислять всё больше
ничем не пользовался и достигал всего
здесь я считаю что можно было бы как раз
я Рату за то что вот сократить вот эти
предметные то есть давать обзорные как
бы знания но больше давать На социальные
вещи такие как финансовый учёт в школе
например Это очень важно решение проблем
очень важно коммуникации очень важно
критическое мышление очень важно
какие-то такие социальные которые
реально нам каждый день в жизни нужны а
к сожалению в жизни-то нас этому не учат
тот же личный бренд убеждения Там и так
далее и так далее
Поэтому с точки зрения вообще хода Я
считаю образование само по себе конечно
классный фильтр этим надо интересоваться
и так далее но когда вы выбираете
команду Я у меня много лет я этим
занимаюсь я общаюсь в основном С
командами так как я инвестор Я в
операционки был только короткий
промежуток времени всё остальное время я
в операционки никогда не был я работаю С
командами И как я лично вот выбираю
команды я первое на что смотрю первое на
что смотрю Это насколько горят глаза у
основателя У лидера команды то есть
вовлечённость Потому что если человек не
вовлечен то его талантом цена ноль его
дипломом и его талантом цена ноль если
он не
вовлечённость если человек волен Он буде
подкат читать книжки стать Сделает да На
это потребуется больше времени Да он
совершит больше ошибок больше шишек
набьёт но он сделает а очень часто
приходят люди вот такие с таким
образованием увлечённость нет которые
работают с 9 до 6 потом уходит домой и
нифига не делают это люди как раз
не сталкиваюсь с Любой командой И вообще
когда принимаю решение о том
инвестировать в компанию или нет В
первую очередь я смотрю насколько
основатель больной этой идее заражён
готов работать это для меня важно второе
Вот я и проинвестировать
классов знал бы может быть я
подумал Ну даже образование не спросил а
и для меня вот это на самом деле очень
очень важно Потому что когда ты
инвестирует в любой стартап в любой
бизнес а нужно понимать что они конечно
приносят бизнес-планы и проекты Но это
всё вилами по воде сказано это будущее
будущее базово
неопределённо так вот если мне говорят
вот надо выйти в океан который штормит
то Я предпочту людей не с образованием а
те которые
заряжены конечно хорошо если среди них
есть люди Я бы я бы так исходил я брал
бы заряженных людей и из них выбрал бы
те у которых высшее образование Ну
лучшее образование а потому что смотрите
заряженных меньше чем образованных вот
есть два способа можно выстроить всех
образованных и оттуда найти заряженных Я
иду по-другому я
выстраивают нахожу и говорю Мне нужны 10
которые пойдут со мной в океан который
штормит потому что дух дух нужен очень
часто в этом неопределённом будущем
очень много преград проблем Это нужен
дух нужен дух нужна преданность люди
чтобы пёрли до конца Поэтому вот это
очень важно как вы видите команда
команду как правило членов команды никто
здесь не нашёл через HR агентство либо
рекрутеров поэтому через рекрутеров Вы
можете нанять коллектив но команда - это
всё-таки люди которые заряженные которые
больны этой идее и так далее И как
хороший пример Мадьяр показал для того
чтобы расширить поиск команды расширяйте
площадь соприкосновения вас с внешним
миром для этого проявляйте любопытство
ходите в разные кружки развивайте
нетворкинг делайте благотворительные
проекты Я очень много людей себе взял
команду из волонтёров Я вообще люблю
волонтёров Я сам очень часто волонтёр
люблю волонтёров потому что туда
приходят люди во-первых а не за деньги
второе они приходят за идею помогать это
люди дают
я потом что делю людей на берущих и
дающих с берущие ничего не сварить
дающие и соответственно из дающих людей
которые заинтересованы которые готовы
это работать не за деньги то там если я
нахожу людей которые заряжены образованы
и заряжены какой-то идеей Вот это самая
лучшая среда поэтому волонтёр Когда вы
волонтёр и оказываете благотворительные
участвуете в благотворительных акциях
это не только помощь другим это ещ
нахождение в крутой среде Где вы можете
найти членов своей команды Это очень
крутая идея И туда очень час ты Когда
приходишь волонтёры добровольцем в
какую-то Ну неважно причём какое
направление волонтёрство подразумевает
помощь это может быть помощь экологии
помощь в проведении форума какая разница
и очень часто ты смотришь и там такие
крутые люди бывают которые с крутой
зарплатой и так далее они бесплатно
готовят там что-то делают помогают и
думаешь О нифига себе
поэтому даём мы вам сегодня такой
лайфхак Где находить членов команды это
может
быть тот случай когда через
благотворительные акции тот случай когда
вы можете родственников друзей близкий
Круг Ну самое главное чтобы эти люди
были заряжены и готовы были идти с вами
до конца к сожалению у нас
время нашего подкаста подходит к концу
можно говорить конечно очень ещё много
тем много очень интересно тем более с
такими ребятами которые а прошли многое
пооб и сегодня уже достигли определённых
успехов если бы они не достигли Либо они
бы здесь не оказались Э вы всё равно
заметные люди поэтому мы пригласили
каждый своей сфере а большое спасибо
всем участникам гм подкаста Спасибо
нашим зрителям
и здесь ещё важный момент если вы хотите
в целом понимать Ну для того чтобы
понимать хоть ход моих мыслей то что я
думаю о стартапах о развитии бизнеса и
так далее переходите по ссылке в
Telegram канал Я внизу оставлю там У
меня более закрытое
сообщество и даю больше контента про
жизнь про бизнес стартап и так далее на
этом мы заканчиваем Спасибо большое Всем
участникам обязательно подписывайте
подписывай на на наш канал колокольчики
там комменты комменты пишите комменты
кстати Напишите ваши случаи когда вы
стартанул бизнес особенно знаете меня и
всех участников я уверен интересует Меня
интересуют факапы и именно знаете я хочу
сам получить от вас подтверждение вот я
же говорил что каждый раз когда я сам
инициировал какой-то бизнес он у меня
заканчивался плачевно у вас было такое
вот напишите мне интересно это лично мой
опыт или это в целом статистика Ну вот
сегодня мадр дожан сказали что у них
тоже когда они сами инициировали это
было неудачным проектом поэтому напишите
я почитаю в комментах спасибо большое мы
на этом прощаемся до встречи на
следующем ГМ
[музыка]
подкасте